Congressman Jamal Bowman pulled a fire
alarm in the house Cannon office
building on Capitol Hill at a time when
the Democrats were trying to delay a
vote on a GOP stopgap spending Bill the
fire alarm led to of course an
evacuation a full response by emergency
and law enforcement personnel and we
know that this happened and we know who
was responsible for it because security
cameras caught Bowman pulling the fire
alarm because you're in an office
building on Capitol Hill which means
that they're going to be security
cameras everywhere especially right next
to fire alarms in your entire time
existing on this planet you have never
once heard of anyone ever anywhere
pulling a fire alarm in order to open a
door you've never considered doing that
yourself you've never done it yourself
you've never heard of anyone doing it or
considering it you've never been like
walking with a friend down a hallway and
come across a fire alarm and had your
friend turn to you and say is this what
we pressed to open the door nobody has
ever said that to you nobody has ever
asked you that